[Musique]
alors que le président du département
cyrille melchior et le maire et
conseiller départemental du tampon andré
thien ah koon se retrouve derrière un
projet de développement de la filière
équine et la création d'un hippodrome le
monde de l'équitation réunionnais
accueillant grands cavaliers à
l'invitation de la fédération équine
pierre de bat star s'est rendue dans
notre île pour des stages au niveau
équestre pure ça apporte des nouvelles
pistes de travail
ça nous conforte aussi dans ce qu'on
fait et donc voilà c'est vraiment
essentiel on essaye d'en faire venir
deux à trois fois par an dans chaque
discipline là celui ci vient pour
l'obstacle ma perception de la chose
c'est d'être ouvert justement aux
méthodes pour justement améliorer le
niveau local parce qu'on empêche quand
même d'être à 12000 kilomètres de la
métropole
et justement le fait de servir ses des
intervenants comme pierre dumas star ça
va accentuer profiter au bon
fonctionnement de notre discipline cet
écuyer ancien membre du cadre noir de
saumur responsable de la formation à
l'école nationale de l'équitation est
également un ancien cavalier de
compétitions nationales et
internationales alors je suis là depuis
une dizaine de jours est d'abord j'étais
surpris du très bon niveau et des
chevaux et des cavaliers sont des
cavaliers passionnés qui s'investissent
beaucoup avec leurs chevaux et qui ont
besoin d'orienter un tout petit peu la
gymnastique de leur cheval sur le plat
et l'obstacle
je suis venu la demande de cavaliers
pour les aider à orienter leur travail
le travail de leurs chevaux
leur travail a eu en vue de sortir en
compétition les stages de
perfectionnement qui l'ont mené aux
quatre coins de l'île afin que les
cavaliers locaux puissent acquérir de
nouvelles méthodes d'entraînement mais
également parfaire leur technique sur
les différentes disciplines de la
compétition ça nous apporte beaucoup de
points positifs ça me permet de
travailler de chevaux travail et nous
aussi c'est notre position et pour
sortir en concours extra ben ça nous a
dit le coach aussi à nous orienter vers
un travail un peu plus pointu
[Musique]